thank you very much hello good morning
everyone thanks for staying for the last
day after of the meeting and thank big
thanks to the organizers for for setting
up such a such a great lineup it's
really the whole meeting has been a
pleasure from his most of the talks were
quite relevant to what we do in the lab
what I will talk about to you today is
is a story that it started in a lab
maybe maybe three or four years ago when
we we started looking at tri-c data but
I'll in this talk I'll I'll kind of
start to many position myself in in the
context of these problems maybe kind of
coming back to Tuesday's discussion to
kind of give you the idea of whether i'm
more into into a fan of analyzing hi-c
data or more into kind of trying to be
predictive so mm so i think i will not
need much of introduction of the data
itself but i'll give you a first few
slides the idea of where I come from and
then i'll discuss to two methods that we
have developed for this for this task
and give you an an outlook for
applications this is all unpublished but
the code is is finally out and if
somebody wants to use it it's it's
actually available okay so where do I
come from I I'm most I mean the focus of
my lab is basically a gene regulation
and we I started very theoretically as
looking at moles of gene regulatory
networks and it was quite interesting to
look at this in the context of of
development but naturally as I as I try
to look more and more closely at at the
data collected from from animal tissues
you you figure out that this is more
complex than just a transcription factor
like an f2 going after let's say its
target of better tubulin there is much
more mechanism that we need to
understand to actually have some kind of
semantics for the
kind of diagram they're good so
naturally the enhancers came in and and
I spent quite some time you know in
furlongs lab looking at enhancers in
this case it is in drosophila and kind
of trying to understand how a given gene
is regulated by a number of regulatory
elements that are scattered somewhere on
the chromosome most usually on the same
chromosome in the vicinity and this kind
of makes makes make the task of
understanding gene regulation a little
bit more modular these are discrete
elements to two large degree in as far
as as we agree on some sort of some sort
of definition of that's probably a
compromise from from the reality but but
we can actually understand these
semantics of j regulation of a certain
transcription factor better when we know
that this regulation is mediated through
a number of discrete elements are
driving different parts off of the
activity of the gene but due to actually
still see whether whether we understand
how this words mean we need to make
models that actually put these things
together in the context of chromatin and
to this extent we I was involved also in
looking at at models that trying to
actually go and predict gene expression
in this case it's not so much a goal of
actually having a tool to predict gene
expression but maybe I mean for me this
was more about trying to understand
which parts of this image so so in this
case we have genes since with their
location of the chromosome we have some
proteins binding binding to the to the
to the chromosomes in this particular
case these were insulator proteins and
transcription factors and then there's
transcription factors and being in some
modules and then they some of them have
some known activity and then you have
also histone modifications that are
telling you something about the global
activity of this situation but it's it's
not so much I mean we build a model that
was probabilistic and was kind of trying
to was integrating all of that to give a
predictive
a method for for for for trying to see
where a gene is going to be expressed
but it was much more of a exercise in
trying to see whether you gain or lose
something by adding any of these
particular pieces of data and see how
important they are for the accuracy of
the prediction so one of the things that
at this time in 2012 was maybe not so
common to do was to look at the at the
insulator proteins and we we found that
they were really instructive in case of
drosophila genome to see how so you have
for example this is a locus where two
important regulators sits at inman and
back part they're both involved in his
room differentiation but they do
different things and then when you want
to understand of those all of these blue
rectangles are actually putative
regulatory elements if you want to
understand which are of those are
talking to which of the target genes it
is actually quite instructive in this
case they look at the chip chip this
would still chip chip data I think off
in this case I think this is CDC effer
there's a number of other proteins that
are occupying this spot in this spot is
a boundary element so if you if you
would remove it then the regulation of
this region which would become more
complicated so we have we have put this
in into our mathematical model and it
helped us make predictions about where
exactly this gene and the other one will
be will be activated so the important
thing that was already I was already
mentioned here several times is that
these these boundary elements and in one
of the one of the things is they somehow
end up recruiting a number of different
proteins which help the media these
functions we've heard from Lyon it about
the loop extrusion and and and and a lot
of there's a lot of discussion in the
field about how exactly this is working
we don't have exact ways to to look at
this but but one of the things that is
clear they are not only separate you
know things from one another but they
also so this is one example from
drosophila where it is well known it is
well known from I
from the 90s that this sex cons reduced
genus is regulated by elements that are
beyond the loop that loops outfits with
with its regulatory elements so so these
these boundary elements they mediate
contacts as well as separate regulatory
environments and and with my student
pavo we've looked at those and we were
wondering whether we can also similarly
to to some approaches in predicting
regulatory elements whether we can
actually also predict predict these
boundary elements and long story short
using supervised learning we have been
able to to find the locations of those
of those boundary elements where the
relatively good depending so from the
sequence alone you can get about
eighty-five percent of the area under
the curve if you add his new
modifications and proteins you can get
more than ninety percent accuracy so
this is pretty good but we still don't
understand how they are connected to
each other and for this you need really
high C data and I hardly have to yes
here's what does it mean to predict an
insulator so what is that but what the
location location of where where the so
in this case our training said was was
actually from a high C data where from
from sextant and our paper where they
actually looked at the basically
topological features of the optic
chromatin so this section exactly these
lines here so they took hi-c data and
delineated where where the boundaries
are they had about a thousand of those
in the genome where they were confident
that this is really a boundary in
topological sense and we were wondering
whether this is whether you can predict
this for example from sequence an
eighty-five percent of the cases you can
actually predict them from sequence so
that this is going to be a topological
boundary just sequence no just sequence
I mean if you if you add criminal marks
and proteins then it it goes up to two
ninety percent so I don't this is not
really the main topic but as yeah but
but we've been looking at this as well
so it has been shown also by other
people and just to kind of remind
from what liyanage was was and some
other people was we're talking about
before is that there is this two ways of
looking at these high C data so I'll not
go into details of what exactly these
matrices are but already in libram and
iden paper from 2009 it was kind of
observed that there are these a B
compartment so if you look at the
principal components of the signal of
the contact matrix in the hi-c you get
these kind of clear checkerboard
patterns and and these correspond in two
large extent with the with the activity
of the genome so you have this more
active in more inactive compartment and
bless you and and the other approach
which is kind of at the same time the
way to look at this is to look at those
heavy rectangles in the in the compact
matrix basically looking for the domains
and then there can be some hierarchy
seen in this so basically you can have a
very very dense region here and this is
a part of a larger dense region and this
whole thing is actually a dense region
taken out from a part of the chromosome
3 are so so this is still no news I
guess due to everybody here what what is
maybe less advertising in in the in the
papers but it should be quite natural is
that this is really two ways of looking
at the same data and the way we see this
in papers though it's still kind of to
rephrase what remo is saying I mean with
heat maps you can pretty much completely
not show anything from your data so in
this case this is the very same data but
depending on whether you actually look
at this in just the contact frequency or
whether you make a covariance normalize
covariance matrix from this you're
getting you're getting a very different
picture in it also because we don't
exactly know what we're looking for we
don't exactly know we don't have a gold
standard of what exactly does it mean to
segment two segments
chromosomes we are kind of I mean when
we read paper I definitely applies to me
when I read paper cites it kind of your
break out my brain gets into when I see
maps presented this way I kind of look
at the very small contacts when I see
mass presented this way I kind of you
know it's it's more it's more driving
your my thoughts to to the compartments
what I wanted to emphasize is that
actually both these things happen and as
Liam was saying this is usually more
large-scale object and these are usually
smaller scale but in fact there are
there are there is some overlap so there
is some for example this is a larger
compartment within it there's still a be
kind of you still see the checkerboard
pattern and similarly here you have a
denser area with with the checkerboard
pattern in it so it's a it's a hierarchy
and it has been postulated as early as
in 2009 at this clearly is a use a
hierarchical structure that we looking
at so there has been a number of of
tools I'm not really trying to to to be
comprehensive here but it's definitely a
large number of approaches that has been
available in particular so I would
basically divided them into into two you
know two groups one of them would be
including the scaling factor the
directionality index and our mattress
tool buy-in from cows kingsford group
similarly to the statistical potential
one of them is really looking at those
heavy so to speak heavy elements close
to the diagonal so the idea here is
usually that I mean this is a figure
from from level aduke paper from 2014
you usually have a certain mall where
basically you have rectangles that have
a different free contact frequency that
are close to diagonal and then you have
a
less less frequent contacts outside of
this and the idea of segmentation the
really cost function is is to find the
segmentation that is basically has the
the the most the most heavy rectangles
at the diagonal and the least heavy the
other part it's the directionality index
and scaling factor is slightly different
but they actually look at the same thing
just a little bit differently so that
the people some people might recognize
this is actually looking at the left to
right ratio of context but it indeed is
looking for this those triangles so kind
of one more word about their motto so
this is to my knowledge the first
approach it was openly trying to to at
least pose the problem of finding the
hierarchy hierarchy of those domains it
is actually using a parameter so there
is a gamma parameter that you can tune
and if you tune it then you basically
get different segmentations you can see
they're mostly either agreeing all there
is aggregation of domains it's it's a
little bit it's a little bit tricky
because there is no clear idea of how
does the gamma parameter map to the
resulting size of the domains but it is
I think it doesn't definitely deserves
credit for for the first two to state
the problem recently more recently there
was a paper from Anna pombo and Marine
Academy lab where people have been
looking at the the differentiating cells
and their the approach was actually to
use Todd segmentation flat segmentation
as a first approximation and then
aggregate them up into into so basically
you look first for the heavy triangles
and then you look for heavy rectangles
between them and then you get a tree
like structure of the domain so it's
it's it's an interesting case way where
this is basically using
turkey above tat so this is instead of
using this kind of PCA like algorithms
that actually look for checkerboard
pattern this this is actually looking
for super tabs or meta tags however you
you like to call them so what would we
started to develop actually the master
student who was responsible for that is
it's cliche who's sitting here because
he now works at Google and it was closed
it short drive for him to to actually
listen what's going on so this is where
we now call share power which stands for
simple hierarchical profile aggregation
and I'll just I won't we really give you
details but kind of the basic idea is
you start with with matrix you go into
into covariance or normalized covariance
matrix where basically you can think of
every entry in the in the matrix as a as
a Pearson correlation between two
vectors so kind of this boosts the
signal and you kind of we are using
information about the contacts from the
whole vector instead of the instead of
the just this one mij entry and then you
can just use use hierarchical
aggregation basically you look for the
two nearest vectors and then you
aggregate them and so on and so forth
and the question is where should you
stop doing this and and to find where
you should stop this we actually devised
a relatively simple trick so basically
as you look at how the Pearson
correlation coefficient changes as you
move up the tree we found kind of
through observation that it usually
shows first a certain number of high
correlation high correlation merges and
then it drops down and and the kind of
new model is here that actually this
should be this should be actually a flat
a linear decay so what we're doing is
we're basically trying to see first of
all whether we see this kind of
enrichment or whether there is actually
a population of emerges that is actually
better than than the kind of normal flat
decay and if we see that the BI linear
model is fitting better than the linear
model we are actually choosing this
inflection point and and we're cutting
here so basically we aggregate
everything
in here and do not aggravate those and
this is the one step off Sherpa
algorithm and then we merge those we
merge those those vectors and average
them and then we basically you start
over so you calculate pearson
correlations of those average vectors
aggregate them find inflection point and
so on and so forth and this is what you
get so kind of the way this is fragment
of a human chromosome in what you get
here does these blue triangles is the
output of this algorithm the green here
is is an output I think of armatus and
in it really does agree with with
majority of those doors what we arguably
get is we have a lot of more in the
lower spectrum so these kind of high
resolution things that we get are mostly
due to the fact that using this kind of
covariance normalized covariance matrix
instead of instead of just using
searching for heavy triangles yep
correlation on this plot on the left
here this is here I don't understand
what the correlations being computed are
you aggregate within a subtree not the
top on the bottom one or your cube so at
a particular pressure what is it being a
computer person coalition I know so it's
at every merge so let's say then the
most correlated are Victor one and two
and they have a correlation of 4.95 okay
so if I was cut this tree here this
would be you know this will be just a
very beginning and it would be at the
Pearson correlation of all my 95 and
here maybe this is a correlation of 0
point 7 ok and this means i have merged
150 pairs of vectors of pairs of pasta
subtree with 12 in sub K with 3 4 5 is
the average when you at the sea boundary
that you drew in the top right right
yeah how do you compute the correlation
at that one so this is the last merge
that we will be made so this is
basically and we're using complete
linkage clustering so basically this is
we're guarantee that if we cut a
correlation of 4.75 that we kind of we
don't know it what would love
we will be doing we can yep how are you
computing that number between those two
yes this is the complete linkage so
basically this is the lowest correlation
between so if you have two clusters that
you're merging this is basically the
lowest correlation between any two
vectors in the in the costumes follow-up
question so you're saying that you get
many finds more fine-scale resolution
right but if other hierarchical methods
don't they have a parameter that they
could tune to do that as well there is
it's not so easy it's not so
straightforward so the in principle yes
but it's most of the methods that use
the kind of heavy triangle kind of
approach this is not so straightforward
so for example directionality index or
or are matters it's not so easy I mean
I'm not saying it's not possible to do
it's definitely you know upon a certain
you know you could definitely make them
be very selective I think we've done
going into this kind of correlation
matrix instead of the the actual count
matrix it's a bit tricky so kind of a
little bit bigger you can actually do
this on the scale of whole chromosomes
it gives you some large-scale elements
some small it's it's kind of this is how
it looks like yeah five minutes okay so
it's going to be quick now so this is
the this is the share program basically
how it works the other approach is kind
of what we found is that these kind of
these large hierarchically aggregated
things once they hit the level of these
a B compartments they're not really very
useful so what we start developing some
time ago is is the other kind of
complementary approach which we called
up power which is kind of optimal PCA
like aggregation said this is a dynamic
Algren this K goes top down now so since
you remember these checkerboard pattern
so what we want to what we want to
optimize now is a segmentation that not
only has heavy triangles along that the
animal but also has a checkerboard
pattern so actually I want to see
negative signal so I want to actually
this is a penalty if I have heavy
elements in this mere in this
place this actually is a penalty for me
so if I decide to put a boundary here I
will actually penalize for over and then
if i put the next boundary here and i'll
penalize for this and I want to have
more contacts in this region area right
so this is specifically going for the
checkerboard pattern and it goes
completely opposite so kind of its its
top down it's it's a cubic in terms of
the size of the matrix so it's the
length of the chromosome so it's not the
fastest but it's it's polynomial and you
can actually find the optimal solution
assuming that the I mean it doesn't go
well with you have break so if you're
it's it's not happening in the data but
if you had actually in theory in theory
you could cook up a matrix that would
not work that this program would not
work on it but but if you assume that
this is somehow noisy proper compartment
segment signal you actually get those
and and the nice part about this is that
when you run both of the tools and the
same matrix what you get typically is
sure pies giving you sure but is giving
you the small stuff and opera is giving
you the larger part so so kind of maybe
two to underline this both of these
methods will stop naturally at a certain
point so so Sherpa will stop when there
is no longer an improvement in
aggregating so it's and it usually stops
at these kind of PCA compartments
because now the next name nor neighbor
from you has really the opposite vector
right so it might actually still have
the context because if you use those
kind of heavy diagonal stuff there will
be a lot of contacts between between
this this compartment and the next
compartment because they're just on the
on the neighboring on the chromosome but
the actual correlation of those vectors
would be very will be negative so Sherpa
will stop at this point usually and
upper will also stop at this point
because because then there is no longer
the checkerboard pattern is not so
prominent inside but you also see some
places that they actually overlap so so
for example here Sherpa can aggregate
this into a larger than the same thing
you get from Appa and and kind of you
can see that they overlap and this is
those places where you see clearly
domain
aggregating with a checkerboard pattern
inside them so this is something that we
have been struggling quite a bit we
quite didn't quite solve it these kind
of cross like patterns in quite solve it
with sherpa but it seems it seems we can
do this so very very quickly about
applications this is none of this is
published so not really give you death
what kind of just do advertise what you
can do with this one thing is you can
compare two different so maybe this is
not so obvious that these are two
different contact maps and you can see
that when you run sharp on them you get
different results and this really
reflects for example here you can see
this domain really doesn't does look
like it has the same structure in both
experiments and here for example you see
clearly that these two domains are
aggregating together while in this
experiment they're not aggregating
together so you can see these kind of
rearrangements they mostly happen at a
very low level so it's not really those
this is below tad level programs we're
gonna have to give you if we run
directional index we would get kind of
this thing as a as a domain and it
wouldn't really let you look at those
kind of rearranging switcher I mean it's
not exactly high resolution data here
but this is kind of giving us hope to
look at kind of switching from one
enhancer environment to another one
hunter environment by a genius kind of
this is where it leads to for us the
other thing that we've we've been
working on and we have some promising
results hopefully hopefully to be
published earnest is looking also at
long range contacts and now that you
have all these domains this is a very
nice setup for for hypothesis testing
about kind of having pairs of domains
that are that are in contact is
specifically in certain cell type or not
specifically in certain cell types oh
it's it's kind of a it's been a
workhorse and we've studied a lot in
terms of in terms of finding these kind
of regions there are not i mean this
particular one is kind of visible so
this is kind of this is a clean signal
and you get from statistical testing
this is the kind of the actual contact
matrix you can see this and if you know
where to look you will actually find
that this this blob is not appearing in
and out in the other in the other
contact matrix
uh how do you distinguish their own
structural variation structure over yeah
we don't yeah I mean it's it once
structure if you really think about rig
so I'll I wouldn't go with this into
cancer cell lines where I would expect
many reorganization chromosomal
reorganizations I didn't know what I
would do I think that this is a I don't
think anybody has solved this kind of
thing yet but but I mean we definitely
didn't but if you have a differentiating
cell line I mean in principle you don't
expect these things to be reorganizing
your chromosomes as they go so I think
it's a I mean we've getting some
meaningful enrichment in terms of
chromatin state at those places yeah
it's not clear whether you know how much
this is in agreement with the domain
structure because here we are only
testing hypotheses about certain domains
at different levels being in touch but
it's a yeah so we've also looked at that
gene expression distribution over
chromosomes kind of just kind of quickly
it does give you an edge over over tab
Todd's because you can really look at
the lower level I disagree even though
we have certain data sets where there's
very different genes that are
differentially expressed all of them the
variance is very nicely distributed a
longer our our domain structure the
other thing that we've also looked at is
the co-expression across species and
again this is reliably at the lower end
of the spectrum there is more of a
difference between random and and random
control and what we get so kind of to
summarize what I'm trying to sell you
here is a set of tools and set of
approaches its I mean it's by no means
this is the only way to do this but I
think that we have after a few years of
work we have found a way to kind of Mary
the the kind of top-down and a bottom-up
approaches of the PCA and and the kind
of looking for those heavy heavy
triangles and in particular in this case
if you want to just remember one thing
that is useful is its I think you
these these these correlation matrices
is really is really a useful thing to do
yeah so this is yeah there's there might
be dead man's reputation one more plug
is that this is this year in the autumn
there will be a school and on
computational approaches to chromatin
organization so if if you are in
interest in these things there will be a
line up of I think it's excellent
speakers there will be fellowship so
we're trying if there are no there are
some people who have been in in the very
same place three years ago when we did
transcriptional regulation school it
will be the very same similar setup we
would try to get fellowships for all the
students if you want to come just let me
know there is a there is a link here and
finally credit so the initial
implementation of sharon burk she who is
sexually sitting here and pavo has been
mostly so this is Pavo Pavo was mostly
involved in in insulator prediction rafa
in arena are now so Rafa is our go-to
guy for four hi-c normalization and he's
done a lot of these experiments with
gene expression correlations arena is
doing mostly the from the stuff I talked
about this is doing the long-range
contacts and Alana was involved in the
another gene expression study and we are
collaborating when a number of people in
particular Eileen was I was giving us
data for for drosophila hi-c and Mina hi
conan from from helsinki live from from
copier sorry it was was kind of to share
with us a high c delta 4 cubic cells and
then this with this i might maybe take
it one or two questions thank you very
much
this higher resolution partition there
get em kind of validation para logically
hopeful for example in the beginning you
have this idea of looking at insulator
so they get more insulated or better
specificity at the higher resolution I
mean so one thing to kind of to to be
clear about here so when I'm when I'm
talking about higher resolution so we
haven't really gotten yet to to these
because there is this rao and other
danger said that is really deeply
sequence human I see when I'm talking
about high resolution so for example
what we use in the in the human data set
we're using it bin size so a single
pixel in those images was on the range
of fifty 250 kb right so this is not
really high resolution in terms of
enhancer promoters single enhancer
promoter interactions so we're not
really replacing capture hi-c or hot
Chaput or whatever you you might want to
really produce singly singular but in
terms of validation of this lower level
this is really kind of I mean I just
showed you this one plot here but this
is kind of so this is a plot of how the
observed correlation of expression goes
as opposed to two two randomized control
and it actually is peaking at the very
lower end and it is we have control so
this is not due to the fact that these
are just smaller elements and these
things are closer or closer on the
genome so so we have we have indications
I wouldn't say that this is completely
proven but we have for example also
looked at replicate reproduce ability
and it seems to be not not getting worse
at the lower level so so these kind of
things make us say this is really we're
looking at something that is real and
not not just kind of you know dividing
arbitrarily dose those segments and
other people have let me do one last
question so yes I'm fine here make sure
is bottom bottom find small scale and
opa top down and find large scale that's
the thing both of them you could remove
your stopping criterion right and they
could sign completes all state but they
have different they haven't BN different
criteria sounds like you're saying is
that you believe that the ones that
polka find a small scale are better than
the ones that shirt over you are better
in some sense and the large-scale ones
are it's not so straightforward to
remove these stopping criteria so kind
of in particular I don't have anything
to point in our but here's the
correlation threshold and we just say
continue just tell you nobody do in
order to split I mean the top down in
particular it has a it as a possibility
to just tell you this is a one triangle
there is no checkerboard pattern in it
right and and it won't go further I mean
there is no reason because the cost
function is this checkerboard planet so
in order to have a split you actually
have to have a negative signal in the in
the you know above the diagonal and this
is this actually leads to to the
situation within not it's it just stops
it's just going to go further and it
happens to be about the same the same
region where were the share puzzles I
mean we could go but it's still we're
trying to find its infliction pollen if
this is linear there's really you know I
mean you could this is just kind of
turning into random random division
because I mean then here you have a
noisy linear signal and you're trying to
just find some blip so it indeed
removing the stopping criteria would
mean that you are that you kind of you
know you just randomly splitting so so
we don't do this it's thank you for tech
again
you